the mayor of the world's northernmost
city has been charged with criminal
negligence over a massive oil spill in
Siberia last month tens of thousands of
tons of diesel fuel have leaked into
local waterways around the city of
Norilsk investigators say the mayor
failed to react quickly enough which
turned the spell from accident into the
Russian Arctic were styled Bell in
living memory environmentalists are
calling it the worst disaster in the
region in living memory more than 20
tons of fuel have leaked into rivers and
waterways in Russia's Arctic north
turning large expanses of water red the
pollution is already damaging ecosystems
and Wildlife it's to say or think that
nothing will perish and that what
happened will go away without a trace
our work has saw dead donkeys today I
myself saw a dead muskrat if a bird
lands on fuel or if a muskrat swims in
fuel it is definitely condemned to death
the spill took place after a fuel tank
belonging to a power plant collapsed
near the city of Norilsk a number of
workers there have already been detained
now the local mare has been accused of
criminal negligence for failing to react
to the impending disaster a coordinator
responds who there are slid when you
start the investigation found that the
mayor of Norilsk
a commission being aware of the amount
of fuel spilled from the did not take
proper measures to respond to the
emergency and to eliminate its
consequences the mayor may have to go to
prison if found guilty investigators
think the incident happened because the
company failed to carry out repairs on
machinery belonging to the plant some
reports suggest equipment became
unstable because permafrost in the area
is melting officials say the situation
on the ground is beginning to stabilize
but that's a full cleanup will take
years
GWS Emily Sherwin is in Moscow following
this story for us hi Emily
how serious are these charges well
they're serious I mean they're criminal
charges criminal negligence that's what
the mayor is being accused of and he
hasn't been taken into custody so far
but if he's found guilty he could face a
prison sentence and this also has I
think the fact that he was that he's
been accused of criminal negligence also
has a political significance symbolic
significance it was clear when this
happened that kind of heads would have
to roll including on the political level
especially after of Vladimir Putin went
on TV to publish publicly admonish
officials for keeping this accident
kind of quiet for two days he he was
really angry and showed that very
clearly and actually other officials
have from the plant itself has all have
also been detained including the head of
the plant and Emily tell us more about
how badly this area of Russia's Arctic
North has been affected by this spill
well we've been speaking to Greenpeace
in recent days and they really have been
emphasizing that this is a huge disaster
one of the biggest in the region in
living memory in recent history the the
subsoil of the region has been polluted
a nearby river has been polluted a
freshwater lake has been polluted which
is one of the main sources of water for
the region and there's concern that the
bigger River as well could be polluted
that flows into the Arctic Ocean
so that could of course have
catastrophic consequences now Narula the
city is often known as Russia's most
polluted city the Norilsk Nickel factory
is based there there behind this
accident and they've been behind
accidents in the past before and
authorities are saying that this
particular accident could
years to clean up dwz Emily Sherman
reporting there from Moscow thank you